saints row's character creator pretty
much lets you make anybody here's just a
few of our favorite creations made by
some really talented people
the saints aren't a flash in the pan
we're here to stay
[Applause]
the four of us founded the saints but it
belongs to all of us
oh
[Music]
whoa things got a little crazy over
there seriously
why does stuff like that keep happening
to us i don't know prison riots
derailing trains it's almost enough to
make you question your whole way of look
out idols on jet skis with machine guns
let's [ __ ] them up hell yeah i'm gonna
head for home
[Music]
so how do you want to do this
i don't know drive to the train figure
out where they're keeping the doe hop
aboard and then
kill the [ __ ] out of anyone who gets
between us and our money i'm gonna need
the nawali fast i'll drop you off and
get him what are you gonna do i guess
plan e
[Music]
you meatheads think you can steal our
heist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you josh yeah
the car is running
you ready what are we doing here just
picking up some stuff and you want me to
ride shotgun yeah just in case should i
wait in the car or come with wait in the
car don't want to freak anyone out
what happened i killed the [ __ ]
dealer and stole his stash seriously we
were just gonna pick up some stuff oh
they're coming after us we're so dead
i'll deal with them you drive
here we go that's where we're gonna die
i'll shoot you myself if you don't calm
down
dead as a door now
so many
[Music]
ah
stay on all sides
just stayed home
i've had enough
[Music]
uh
um
advanced
back up
[Music]
okay
hmm
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
ah
no need for a firearm
[Music]
we must take cover
my time on this world has
i hope this battle starved you
oh great things
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you